welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and the new Morbius trailer
reveals Jared Leto as the Sony
spider-man antihero Morbius the living
vampire hunka hunka who appears to exist
in the venom corner of the Sony
spider-verse but according to a few
Easter eggs a corner net shares a weird
alleyway back to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I am gonna explain who Morbius
is and what the spider-man tie-ins mean
in a shot-by-shot breakdown of
everything you missed in this trailer
it's more a warning in case I predict
anything to accurately and let's get
started Michael I've learned you since
you were a child you even give it you
always have okay this opening clip
introduces us to a young Michael Morbius
a kid with a rare blood disorder that
requires him to walk with crutches in
the comics this condition makes adult
Michael Morbius look beast-like but here
in movie it makes him look like the lead
singer two thirty Seconds to Mars he
attends what looks like a Greek Orthodox
school notice the priests the Greek
lettering and the school name in the
comics Morbius comes from Greece and it
is at this school where he meets his
mentor figure played by Jared Harris
whom I think could be playing a version
of Morbius his friend and assistant in
the comics Nico's but Harris's character
remains unnamed at the moment for
reasons that I'll get to later the music
that we hear is the famous Beethoven
composition he release published 40
years after Beethoven's death with the
identity of this Elise lover remaining a
mystery this song choice could reflect
Morbius his life after death
though it's not dead in the sense that
most vampires are he's a living vampire
more on that bit or it could refer to
Morbius is eternal passion for his love
Martine a woman he can never be with
because he might call the blood out of
her as young Michael recovers in a
hospital ward he shows off his genius by
playing chess against no one it's still
somehow losing pawns look it's a tough
game he moves his Bishop to c4 a nod to
his Greek Orthodox Bishop could this
Jared Harris maybe Nico's be a bishop am
I reading too much into this probably
let's move on if there's a non-secure
disease we'll find it
[Music]
I should have died here's ago
why am I still here not to fix this okay
as he does in the comments dr. Morbius
wins a Nobel Prize yet here during his
acceptance speech he doesn't look so
good I'm wondering if he'll faint and
that could further his desperation into
finding a cure for this terminal illness
and notice that the studio title cards
include these specific wording in
association with Marvel due to the New
Deal inked between Disney and Sony last
year Marvel Studios will continue to
consult on Sony Marvel properties like
Morbius and venom but that does not
firmly make them part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with the Avengers
movies and Thor and Doctor Strange and
all those guys but Morbius and venom do
weirdly share a universe with the
live-action spider-man films homecoming
far from home since those are jointly
Sony and Disney Productions so Tom
Holland could show up in mortgages or
venom - or either of those films
post-credit scenes Holland himself has
two movies left on his contract as
spider-man one of which will be a third
spider-man movie coming in summer 2021
perhaps that could be a sinister six
movie that Morbius in venom 2 could set
up with the second being another unnamed
MCU team-up film in the future now I
have posed a theory in the past that
that deal could have been designed by
Disney to flood their studio with enough
profit from licensing the spider-man
character for merchandise and other
things so that in maybe three or four
years they could be able to buy out
Sony's Marvel properties but enough of
the businessí stuff back to Morbius
Morbius works in a medical research
facility he treats some sick children
but also he seeks treatment for himself
more on that backstory in the next clip
I have a rare blood disease and at a
time
this can be my last chance
you know just something what is so
Morbius works with his research
assistant fiancee Martine Bancroft
played by Adria Arjuna in the comics
Morbius attempts to cure his disease by
experimenting on himself with vampire
bats and electrotherapy transforming
himself into a living vampire with
vampiric powers who is not technically
dead because his vampiric powers come
from science not supernatural means
Morbius was introduced as a horror
themed spider-man villain in the early
70s the amazing spider-man issues 101
and 102 when Peter Parker gave himself
for extra arms cool
the lizard dr. Connors helped Peter
derived a serum from Morbius his blood
that cured him now interestingly later
in the Marvel comics a bite from Morbius
allowed blade to live with the powers of
the vampire and none of the weaknesses
so we could be looking at the origins of
how the MCU might introduce mo Hershel
Holly as blade in the future that is if
they all do end up living in one big
universe more bass eventually became
less of a pure villain and more of an
antihero defending the innocent tortured
over a separation from Martine in order
to try to keep her safe and this whole
antihero approach is kind of the way the
Sony spider-verse featured Eddie Brock
in their adaptation of the venom lethal
protector storyline let's move on that's
not exactly
I want to see you get hurt more than you
already have this would be a cure so
after making a discovery about the blood
of a vampire bat in his lab it now
appears that Morbius has ventured to
this exotic cave and searched for living
swarms of the bats he mentions how this
isn't strictly legal notice how we paid
off the guy in cash perhaps these bats
are like a protected species
Morbius cuts his palm with the blood
trickling down and forming what almost
looks like the Greek letter Y which in
mathematics is the never Indian
irrational number representing the ratio
of a circles circumference to its
diameter the circumference being the
outer perimeter the diameter being the
bisecting line the way that this moment
represents the eternal irrational key
between Morbius --is outer self and that
which divides them internally or maybe
it's just all the ratio between crackpot
and [ __ ] moving on
a what cost
okay Morbius is exposing his blood to
the bats which swarm at him while he
stands behind this device which might
activate something in the blood as his
blood in the bat saliva fuse with a kind
of electrical signal so all of this
means that if you happen to have an open
paper cut on your finger and then you
shock that finger on a doorknob used by
a vampire recently you too can be on
gonca it's science now before we
continue I just gonna want to point out
that this Morbius trailer caught me by
surprise I happen to not get a whole lot
of sleep the night before one way I was
able to wake up from the dead and power
through this was with a nice can of bang
energy by the way thanks to these guys
for sponsoring the video every can of
bang is 16 ounces that's right there are
no 12 ounce wimpy cans here that
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and has zero calories yet
tastes great with over 30 different
flavors to choose from one of those
great flavors to choose from cotton
candy and you know what it's not like
that overly sugary bite of cotton candy
that we grow out of it's just like an
essence of it that's really kind of nice
check out a bang on their Instagram you
can get 25% off your order and bang -
energy calm when you use the code new
rock stars 25 are there you can get a
variety 12-pack with a dozen of their
flavors flavors like pina colada
and cotton candy and rainbow unicorn
three flavors that I feel like are
having a blast party all the time thanks
again to bang energy for sponsoring this
video again get 25% off at bang - energy
calm using the co2 new rock stars 25 and
follow the inventor a bang on Instagram
ad bang energy that's CEO and let's move
on with the rest of the trailer
okay this trailer now switches into
early 2000 superhero movie mode as
Morbius feels the effect of his
self-treatment
breaking the glass of a containment cell
and rising to his feet without these of
crutches more of these effects in the
next clip
[Music]
more alive than ever
the increased strength is speed
I gotta say I'm pretty surprised to see
how much this Morbius movie appears to
be embracing that imagery you know
considering this visual is so evocative
of another superhero now you got to
imagine the Dark Knight would see this
and feel pretty protective of its brand
swore to me you will steal my move look
through this swarm on the blackboard in
the background you can see Morbius is
math notes including some line graphs in
the word concentration perhaps he's
trying to calculate how much of a blood
concentration he needs in his digestive
tract to stay alive since presumably he
wants to attack as few people as
possible then we get a classic
gratuitous before-and-after shot of Leto
that is before when the lighting was an
unflattering fluorescent diffusion and
after when it was switched to a
flatteringly aimed single overhead key
now the MCU is equally guilty of this
kind of thing but the transformative
before-and-after aspect parallels that
tobey maguire Peter Parker shot in the
first Sam Raimi spider-man
Morbius uses super-strength to tire flip
this heavy looking tomb it's actually
kind of looks like the tombs of the
Knights Templar maybe this will be used
as that kind of vampire sarcophagus and
then it uses a form of telekinesis or
teleportation summoning to summon this
ball with a movement releasing this
ribbony smoke it's actually kind of
similar to the effect used for
Nightcrawler and the x-men movies if you
remember I like how it appears to
distort all of the air around him kind
of like this summoning requires all the
nearby air to bend and displace in order
to move it more of this effect in the
next clip the ability to use
echolocation
and then overpowering urge to consume
blood
[Music]
okay here morbius parcours through this
mansion hallway knocking over artwork
the ribbon effect leaves this purple
trail behind him which you can see stems
from a purple cape suggesting they may
give Morbius a similar wardrobe that he
wears in some of the comics he passes
this painting that looks like it
contains two figures from Elizabethan
art maybe this is part of the same
collection is that Knights Templar
looking tomb and then we see another
power echo location which Morbius uses
to see room that you can already plainly
see with normal vision his pupils
contract as the sclera milks over
similar to the way Eddie Brock's pupils
were affected by that Venom symbiote to
see when this happens to your eyes it
means you are in the third best Marvel
movie universe as Morbius talks about
his overwhelming urge to consume blood
there's a shot of this boat followed by
shots of him attacking these gunmen
onboard that boats in the comics Morbius
conducts his experiment on a yacht over
water but then he goes overboard and
then is rescued by the crew of another
boat whom he attacks and kills we could
be seeing a version of that here on to
the next clip far are we allowed to go
but fix something that's broken
okay a lot of interesting goodies here
first Morbius changes out of an orange
prison jumpsuit into some stolen clothes
as he passes this poster of smarter man
with murderer tagged over it this is
actually the loading screen artwork of
the Sam Raimi era spider-man from the
ps4 game flipped horizontally murderer
written on it suggests that we're seeing
the aftermath of spider-man far from
home remember which ended with a Jay
jonah Jameson's Daily Bugle website
Aaron Mysterio's propaganda to paint
Peter Parker as a public menace who
killed the heroic martyr Mysterio
according to casting rumors and IMDB JK
Simmons may appear in this film as well
which could also tie in with the events
of venom in which Jameson's son John
Jameson was the life foundation
astronaut who died early in the film
also on that wall behind Morbius are
Flyers tagged with the symbol used by
the Zodiac killer could just be graffiti
but I have a theory on this that could
explain how all of these Sony
spider-verse films will tie together
next there's a shot of the cops that we
saw chasing them earlier in the field on
the right is al Madrigal as FBI agent
Alberto Rodriguez partner - Tyrese
Gibson as CIA agent Simon Stroud who in
the comics was the agent tasked with
hunting down Morbius and other horror
themed villains like man wolf
interestingly Stroud as some kind of
bionic exoskeleton got--let on his arms
and sees a kind of vampire hunter I
wonder if this gauntlet fires anti
supernatural projectiles another shot in
a subway station shows Matt Smith that
actor who's playing the villain looks
his crown who in the comics goes by
crown and later hunger he is Morbius his
friend who suffers from these same rare
blood disease he actually might have
been that kid in the background of the
hospital ward that we saw earlier and
before we move on Morbius screams in
agony as he sits atop this body of
another figure in the comics Morbius
accidentally kills his friend Nico's
which plagues them with guilts from
there forward perhaps this is Jared
Harris as Nico's here maybe Morbius
kills his beloved mentor figure onto the
next clip - the remedy
worse than the disease
they hear a panicked orderly or nurse or
lab tech flees down a hallway with of
course terrifying flickering emergency
lights to kind of screw in those bulbs
not sure if she's running for Morbius or
crown here and then we get our clearest
ever look at Morbius is vampiric form
red eyes nostrils upturn bangs pinched
brow and scariest of all Tommy Wiseau
hair the blood that's tearing apart and
then the Morbius tidal in which the blue
lifeforce drains down into a layer of
blood and then on to the biggest reveal
in the final clip Michael Morbius at the
end of doing a little good guy paying up
to Oh 80 so Michael Keaton returns as
Adrian Toomes aka vulture last seen
incarcerated at the end of spider-man
homecoming in the MCU which ties the
events of this film even more closely to
Tom Hollands spider-man tooms is wearing
the same white inmate jumpsuit we saw
him in suggesting that maybe he and
Morbius crossed paths when they're both
incarcerated also on this list of Spidey
villains behind bars at the moment is
Mac Gargan scorpion who swore revenge on
spider-man as well as Cletus Kasady
carnage in the post-credits scene of
venom now we also know that Kraven the
hunter may also be part of this story
with a set photo showing a craven
catering truck Bo keen Woodbine shocker
is still at large and there are plenty
of conspiracy level rumors suggesting
that Mysterio could have faked his death
so circling back on that zodiac symbol
the Zodiac killer was most active we're
in the San Francisco Bay Area where
Eddie Brock lives which is adjacent to
the San Quentin prison where Cassidy is
kept - perhaps this could all be
pointing at a sinister six team-up of
spider-man villains in prison on the
west coast and a coordinated prison
breakout comment down below with your
theories on how this Morbius film could
connect to the rest of the Sony
spider-verse follow me on instagram and
twitter at EA vas and follow the new
rock stars on social media and subscribe
to new rock stars for breakdowns of
everything you love and be sure to check
out our amazing new Q&A series the big
question in which film and I give you
too much information about how weird and
messed up these Marvel characters are
when you apply real world science and
history to them kind of like drunk
Mythbusters you'll love it thank you for
joining me bye
[Music]